[Music]
on this monday night an afghan waiting
to start his new life in canada killed
what happened days before his death it
was very harnessing for son dreading
russia's revenge the potential ripple
effects if a bombing that killed a putin
ally's daughter
violent arrest the consequences of this
police beating caught on camera plus
historic mission on the horizon we're
going back to the moon in order
to learn to live to work to survive
nasa's moon bound mega rocket and
canada's key role
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us one year after afghanistan fell to
the taliban the situation has become
even more dangerous for afghans who work
closely with western governments and
charity groups
now global news has learned an afghan
man who worked with the canadian ngo war
child and who applied to come to canada
has been killed jeff semple has the
details in our top story tonight
saudia and her children are afraid to
show their faces we're protecting their
identity because for years she worked
for a canadian organization promoting
women's rights and education in
afghanistan
but when the taliban retook control last
year she went into hiding they
definitely against
the
women empowerment programs she says her
work for women and for a canadian
organization makes her a target because
of the working with the canadian
programs
they called me canadian spy
one year ago she applied to move to
canada as a refugee but still hasn't
received a response from ottawa and this
month that waiting game turned deadly
for one of her colleagues
office oklaki who worked in kabul for
the canadian founded charity war child
was stabbed to death it's unclear who
was responsible or why he was targeted
it was very innocent person very
handsome person one week before his
death his friend says he received a
threatening phone call they told them
you should stop your work with the
foreigners
if you do work
will tell you she says aki had also
applied to go to canada but hadn't
received a response
when the taliban took control one year
ago this month ottawa committed to
accepting 18 thousand afghans who had
supported canadian development programs
but so far only around seven thousand or
just over a third have arrived in canada
and we can't help everyone but we are
responsible for helping those who are at
danger because they worked with us
because they represented canadian values
and canadian programs another charity
called canadian women for women in
afghanistan spent 20 years working with
canadian funds to promote women's rights
and education over the past year their
progress has been erased the executive
director says most of their staff remain
trapped still waiting for ottawa to
respond to their refugee applications
they are either in afghanistan at very
high risk of death of detention of
torture um minimally of harassment by
the taliban of intimidation or they're
in third countries like pakistan so they
left us behind
sadia and her children recently fled
across the border to pakistan now unable
to go to work or school
and afraid their fate will be the same
as akhlokhi's
jeff semple global news
ukraine is rejecting russian claims that
keeve was behind the death of a
political commentator daria dugina the
29 year old is the daughter of a
prominent russian nationalist and she
died in a car bombing in moscow over the
weekend
now there are fears her death could
trigger an escalation in russia's war on
ukraine our redmond shannon reports
flag day in russia a nation at war even
if war is not the word being used by
moscow
flags in keeve too along with a lineup
of captured russian tanks independence
day marking the end of soviet rule is
wednesday which happens to be exactly
six months since russia's invasion began
on the weekend president vladimir
zelinsky said russia might be planning
particularly ugly attacks to coincide
with the date so mass gatherings will be
banned in kiev
moscow is likely smarting from recent
attacks deep inside crimea the ukrainian
region annexed by russia eight years ago
and now there's the fallout from
saturday's killing of daria dugina the
daughter of far-right russian ideologue
alexander dugan russia's secret service
claims it has cracked the case already
accusing a ukrainian traveling with her
twelve-year-old daughter of planting the
bomb and fleeing to estonia an adviser
to zielinski calls it russian propaganda
as ever speculation is rife as to what
is really going on so this could be one
of these psychological operations of
here
this happened and now
ukraine is guilty and now we have to
also discuss this at the negotiation
table ukrainian canadian defense
consultant lada rozlicki says dark humor
is the weapon of choice many ukrainians
will be using to get through this week
we will celebrate and we will use that
humor but we're all afraid some revenge
from the kremlin may be exacted here in
the russian-controlled city of mariupol
ukraine says russia is setting up a show
trial for captured ukrainians from the
azov battalion planned it says
for wednesday redmond shannon global
news london
independent international inspectors
could visit the russian-held zaparisia
nuclear power plant in the next 10 days
the facility has been the target of
shelling in recent weeks with both sides
blaming each other leading to growing
fears over the risk of a nuclear
accident last week putin said the
international atomic energy agency
should be able to visit the site and
russia's parliament will meet thursday
to discuss plans the economic
consequences of the war are being felt
in many parts of the world including
germany it is heavily reliant on russian
gas today the german chancellor was in
montreal part of a canadian trip with
energy as a major focus gas shortages
are an increase in concern for the
largest economy in europe and as dan
spector reports questions are growing
about how canada might be able to help
coming together at what prime minister
trudeau called an historic bilateral
meeting with german chancellor olaf
schultz it didn't take long for the two
leaders to blast vladimir putin for his
invasion of ukraine putin made a
terrible mistake germany is supporting
ukraine intensely trudeau said while
putin sought to fracture the west the
conflict has brought allies like canada
and germany even closer together canada
needs a strong germany and germany needs
a strong canada now the question is how
quickly the friendship can help
alleviate germany's looming energy
crisis germany relies heavily on russian
gas and moscow has been accused of
holding back supply in a retaliatory
move against western sanctions that's
caused prices to soar just months before
winter and it just means that people
aren't going to be able to afford to
heat their homes properly that they're
going to have to curtail industries that
are energy intensive we are working hard
to become independent of this gas supply
the two leaders defended canada's
decision to allow turbines used on
russia's state-owned pipeline to be
repaired in montreal a choice that
caused outrage in ukraine what we have
done is remove the excuse that russia
had
to blame someone else anyone else for
their decision
to weaponize
energy policy canada has an abundance of
natural gas most of it coming from
western provinces as germany scrambles
to increase its capacity to import the
prime minister is not convinced it makes
sense to move gas all the way to the
east coast for export to europe there
needs to be a business case it needs to
make sense analysts wonder what the
priority will be the need to push toward
a green economy or building capacity to
send gas directly to our allies so it
all comes down to pipelines and ports or
rail to get it to to ports right now our
best capacity is to continue
to contribute to the global market the
chancellor's visit will continue with an
official dinner in toronto then the two
leaders are scheduled to travel to
newfoundland where they'll sign an
agreement for canada to send clean
hydrogen to germany dan specter global
news montreal
the former rcmp commanding officer in
nova scotia testifying today at the
inquiry into the april 2020 mass
shooting of 22 people lee bergeron
admitted that more than two years later
none of the rcmp internal reviews into
the incident have been completed as
calum smith reports she was also asked
about her perception of any political
interference in the police investigation
yes lee bergeron was nova scotia rcmp's
commanding officer during the april 2020
rampage retiring last october before the
inquiry began but family members weren't
satisfied with her answers or lacked
thereof too many questions monday from
what she has said
not getting a whole lot from what she
said absolutely nothing
all for her answers or i don't know or i
can't speak to that
to me that's totally unacceptable being
the top cop in nova scotia bergerman was
asked about internal rcmp reviews none
of which have been completed she said
that's due to capacity and ongoing
investigation and the inquiry itself
do you think that the next active
shooter is going to wait until these
reviews are complete
well i can't comment on that
get it done because while you're there
it's fresh we're going on what 28 months
now
and not a lot of things been done she
said morale after the incident got bad
due to the traumatic crimes and negative
press bergeron admitted communication
about the killing rampage didn't go well
i'm hoping like some really good lessons
learned come out of that but she said
other parts of the response went very
well bergerman said she believes the
force would be in a better position
today to respond to a mass casualty
given some lessons learned like those
communication gaps response details and
the emergency alert system but she also
said the force didn't have adequate
resources recommending a review of the
provincial police service agreement
bergeron was asked if she believed there
was political interference in the
investigation following an april 28 2020
phone call with commissioner brenda
lucky after that phone call that was my
impression as well that there was
political interference yeah attempted
lucky will testify tuesday and we're
expected to hear questions on rcmp
culture after action reviews nova scotia
rcp leadership and supervision and the
role of communications within the force
callum smith global news halifax
the pleas to help canada's health care
system coming up what some of canada's
premiers are calling for
canada's ongoing healthcare struggles
the focus of a summit in new brunswick
today the premiers of four provinces
discussed possible solutions and once
again called on the federal government
for financial help but as karen
lieberman reports those on the front
lines have little hope for change
anytime soon
hospitals big and small right across the
country are grappling with widespread
staffing shortages those most worse off
are closing emergency departments it has
been a time bomb but you know i think
the fuse is getting very short if not
already blowing up dr steve flindahl an
er doctor of 20 years is preparing to
head in for a shift at a toronto area
hospital anything from you know zones
closing early
to being severely understaffed with
nurses one of the busiest areas in one
of the hospitals i work at had one nurse
caring for the whole zone
and it's because they were just so short
in the town of st mary's ontario north
of london the hospital's er is closing
at five o'clock a result of continued
health human resource shortages it makes
me sad to hear the staff cry before and
after shifts
and that's across the province it's a
nurse wrote that
a nurse wrote that and sent it to me
the ontario nurses association says the
backlog isn't only in the er
it's widespread i'm hearing a lot from
labor and delivery
a lot because that is such a specialized
field we look forward to having a
collaborative
relationship with the federal government
this this is a team canada approach that
we need to take in moncton the premier
of ontario met with his atlantic
counterparts to discuss canada's
struggling health care system and call
for ottawa to step in
also i want medical professionals to
give us their best ideas uh not just
more of the same and hope for the best
there's a significant discussion around
accreditation
of those health care professionals that
were trained in another jurisdiction
another part of the world even and how
do how do we how do we make sure that we
can we can get them accredited here
but this emergency physician says these
suggestions won't translate into
immediate solutions there's absolutely
zero indication that anything has
substantially changed other than long
term solutions that will have no impact
this winter
karen lieberman global news toronto
impactful investigation ahead how
trump's latest legal troubles are
translating to political points
weeks after an fbi search of his florida
home over taken classified documents the
legal troubles may be deepening for
donald trump but as the former president
launches a lawsuit against the fbi the
controversy seems to be rallying more
republican support behind him and that
could play a pivotal role in the
approaching u.s midterm elections and
beyond washington bureau chief jackson
proskow takes a look at the impact of
the ongoing trump investigation jackson
pharah a majority of americans about 57
percent say the investigations into
donald trump should continue but when
you divide things up by political party
that's where things get really
interesting since the fbi search of
donald trump's mar-a-lago home support
for trump amongst republicans has
actually shot way up and right now when
republicans are asked if they're
primarily supporters of trump or the
party the number who say trump first has
spiked up 7 percent since the search
while support for party is down 8
percent now that's all bad news for
republicans like florida governor ron
desantis who are expected to challenge
trump for the republican nomination for
the presidency in 2024 it also means
that november's midterm elections will
likely be viewed by voters as more of a
referendum on trump who of course isn't
actually on the ballot trump supporters
have really said that they'd be with him
no matter what and even if it is you
know nuclear secrets or some other sort
of uh compromising material on others
they'll probably just say it was planted
there they believe in their guys so much
that they will
take whatever new excuse he gives us for
for what's there on the investigation
into the classified documents recovered
from mar-a-lago the judge who authorized
the search warrant hinted today that
he's unlikely to release much more that
would be meaningful he called the
evidence reliable and echoed the
government's concern that releasing too
much information would jeopardize the
ongoing investigation and key here the
witnesses now the justice department has
until thursday to provide a redacted
version of the affidavit used in the
investigation at which point the court
will decide whether or not to make any
of it public
farah
jackson prosco in washington thank you
so much jackson he was the face of the
u.s coveted 19 response but dr anthony
fauci is stepping down after more than
50 years of serving his country
the 81 year old white house chief
medical advisor announced he's leaving
his government roles this december
calling them in honor of a lifetime to
pursue the next chapter of his career at
the height of the pandemic and despite
public disagreements with then-president
donald trump fauci spearheaded america's
public health measures in another
statement president joe biden says the
country is stronger more resilient and
healthier because of him
in arkansas officer use of force is
being investigated after a violent
arrest caught on camera and a warning to
you that some images you're about to see
might be disturbing the video shows
three officers restraining a man on a
sidewalk on sunday and one of them
punches his head repeatedly another
knees him in the leg the man was treated
in hospital he faces several charges
including mischief and trespassing for
allegedly threatening a gas station
worker the three officers have been
suspended pending the outcome of a state
investigation
history is being made in singapore the
nation will repeal a colonial era law
that banned sex between men
there were celebrations as the country's
prime minister made the announcement
during his national day rally speech on
sunday lgbtq plus groups are calling it
a win for humanity but warned new bans
on same-sex unions could entrench
discrimination
a small step to another giant leap up
next nasa's latest mission sets the
stage for our lunar comeback
some stunning images from nasa's webb
telescope are giving scientists new
clues about the biggest planet in our
solar system
the high resolution infrared pictures of
jupiter showing jupiter's faint rings
and huge aurora in a level of detail we
have never seen before scientists now
pouring over the images to learn more
about how the planet's different bands
of storms and clouds interact and for
any insight about the composition of
jupiter's inner layers
and if everything goes according to plan
one week from today nasa's artemis
rocket will lift off starting an
unmanned 42-day mission to orbit the
moon as eric sorensen reports that 2
million kilometer round-trip will be a
final test of nasa's latest rocket
platform ahead of missions to return
astronauts to the moon within three
years
on the launch pad in florida ready to go
the most powerful rocket ever built
artemis one without a crew will test
drive the spaceship that will eventually
carry astronauts deeper into space than
ever before the first mission will
circle the earth then set course for
several days to the moon artemis one
will fly just a hundred kilometers from
the surface of the far side of the moon
a hold your breath moment for the
mission then a much wider orbit for two
weeks before its slingshots back to
earth 42 days after liftoff the aim is
not just to go to the moon we're going
back to the moon in order
to learn to live to work to survive
how do you keep humans alive in those
hostile conditions one of canada's four
active astronauts will be among the crew
that takes the next artemis mission in
2024 that will also circle far beyond
the moon canada will be the second
country in the world to go into deep
space
right
that flight will go out for again an
extended mission circling around the
moon testing out all kinds of systems
when humans first went to the moon half
a century ago it was an all-american
enterprise but canada's robotics notably
the canadarm made this country a major
player in space when a new lunar
orbiting space station gateway goes up
in two years the latest canadarm3 will
maintain the platform from its
laboratories the canadian manufacturer
will be able to control canadarm from
brampton ontario though at a distance of
400 000 kilometers this canadarm will
also have to think for itself we will
only communicate with this space station
once every few days
and in between the artificial
intelligence-based system will cause the
robotic system to conduct its tasks in
three to four years a third mission will
put humans on the moon this time at the
south pole where areas have gone without
sunlight for billions of years this is a
new part of the moon it's a place that
we've never explored the artemis
missions are stepping stones to a
destination tens of millions of miles
away the planet mars and canadians will
be crucial partners exploring our solar
system eric sorensen global news toronto
it's just incredible how far this
technology has come and of course we'll
be covering that for you in a week
that's global national for this monday
night i'm farah nasser and on behalf of
our whole crew here at global national i
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your canada is mary's town newfoundland
and labrador we love seeing your canada
so please keep emailing us your pictures
to viewers and know globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night